[Music]
welcome to session 55 of the worlds of
speculative fiction series
this time around we are reprising an
author who we discussed very early on in
the series when it was in its first year
when it was first beginning
and that is
a e van vote or voikt however you want
to pronounce it it's supposed to be vote
apparently but i'm not going to knock
anybody for
mispronouncing it any more than i
criticize people for saying socrates
instead of socrates or anything like
that and
previously we discussed
his trilogy of the world of null a
and this time we're going to be looking
at two other novels that fit into a
particular narrative universe in which
the
weapon shops and the empire of isher are
the two main polarities and sometimes
this is just called the weapon shops and
isher or isher civilization
uh
narrative universe and novels and so
what we what we have here
are two novels both of which are fairly
short i mean this entire book is only
352 pages
and it includes the weapon makers and
the weapon shops of isher
now
these are both what we call fix ups and
we're going to talk about
the meaning of that and and how it
applies to uh then vote uh in a little
bit
what we usually do in these sessions
is a good bit of attention to world
building so we're going to outline the
main traits of the issuer weapon shops
universe including
some discussion of the guy who's a
character who helped to originate and
guide both of them as we find out which
is a very typical thin vote
thematic
and i do want to spend a bit of time on
biography of van vote and how he comes
to
put these together into novel form
around the time that he does both of
these are you know coming from earlier
material which is being stitched
together and worked through and that's
the way that van vote and and many other
pulp sci-fi authors did what they did
i think i would be remiss to not also
discuss the
critical reception
not just of these novels but of then
vote in general
so we'll talk about that and in
particular
damon knight who just savaged van vault
in in some of his
works but later came to you know back
off a little bit he's still pretty
negative about van vote but you know
what is it that people actually
like about this guy
um and his his plots philip k dick
actually thought that null a was was
quite good and i think we can say
similar things
about these we don't have to be
uncritically
uh you know
you know
receptive to it or uh we don't have to
praise it to the moon but we also don't
have to say that it's the worst stuff
whatsoever
in science fiction it's probably
somewhere
in between they're good uh easy quick
stories to get through there is a lot of
interesting stuff happening in them
i will say i think that that van vote is
kind of an acquired taste for many i got
my taste when i was
very young so if you'll indulge me i'll
go a little bit down memory lane my
uncle eubert
who is a great bibliophile
i've talked about him elsewhere i'll
actually perhaps link the video about
him he was he was a man who had at best
a fourth grade formal education but was
one of the best read people who i've
ever met in my life and a great promoter
of books and literacy and reading for
its own sake and he was into science
fiction so he had some
really great things in his library it
was there i was introduced to for
example cord wayne or smith or
c.l moore and some of the others but
uncle eubert had a
big thick
volume that actually had three classic
van vote
stories in it one of them was the world
of null a right
another was the voyage of the space
beagle
and then there was slan so none of those
are this one but that's what got me into
reading van vote and then you know
the one of the stories that that one of
these novels is based on
um had a lot of currency it's in a lot
of anthologies the weapon shops of isher
and so i got introduced to to him there
and i've been reading van vote really
since i was a child and enjoying him
quite a bit
some of his books are a little bit hard
to get your hands on so it depends on
what your library holdings look like
these are fairly easy to get and they're
you know again found in this nice uh
hold it all in your hand volume
that's got both of these stories i kind
of wish that van vote had written more
things in this universe
fleshing it out further but you know you
get what you get
so we're going to talk a lot about world
building we're going to talk about van
vote's biography a bit we're going to
talk about critical reception
and then we're going to hit on
philosophical themes probably the big
elephant in the room
pun intended
is the weapon shops themselves and
there's their slogan which the nra
co-opted for their own
purposes almost like a nefarious
organization that van vote if he were
around today they would all be villains
right in his book they wouldn't be
heroes or anything but this idea that
the access to to weapons is what
provides for freedom within a complex
system that could be corrupt or
tyrannical so we're going to talk about
that we're going to talk a lot about
ethics we're going to talk quite a bit
about
some of the
you know notions of of like ruling
behind the scenes and some some other
great philosophical
themes as well it's always
interesting digging into van vogt
so
let's buckle up and jump right in
in order to adequately contextualize
these two empire of issuer novels the
weapon makers weapon shops of isher we
don't really need to go over all of even
votes
long biography
we can just concentrate on a certain set
of periods that are particularly
important for understanding
what kind of novels these are and
what what the orientation of them
is
so
there's two things really to keep in
mind one is that if you if you look at
the timeline
of avant volt's life right in 1944
he moves to hollywood california that's
three years after he's decided to become
a professional writer and in in 45 the
world of null a stories are serialized
in 46 slan and weapon makers of isher
are coming out then we've got book of
patah
more null a series and then finally the
world of null a being published in
1948
in 1950
there's a beginning of a period
of involvement with dianetics and when
you hear that term either you know what
it means or you've or you know you don't
know what it means and it just sounds
kind of vaguely cool or forbidding
depending on whether you associate it
with the
church of scientology established by
another science fiction author
who the van votes were in close contact
with and that's l ron
hubbard
and
dianetics itself is
i mean you can see it at like on
bookshelves and in bookstores at
airports and stuff like that there used
to be advertisements for it all the time
on television with a volcano exploding
and stuff like that so dianetics is you
could say the precursor to
scientology right it's a
complex
psychological theory that was developed
by l ron hubbard was not accepted by the
psychiatric or psychological
establishment which may be some of the
roots of his animosity
and dismissiveness towards other forms
of psychology psychiatry and
psychotherapy but in any case it held
out some some promise and if you ever
read the dianetic stuff you you see that
there's a lot of things that hubbard is
actually just pulling out of other other
places and bringing in and kind of
putting together and uh van vogt thought
that this was you know had some
potential to it and it kind of fits in
with some of the other things that van
vogt was
interested in
uh you know a general semantics and and
you know all these other sorts of things
and so interestingly enough
he becomes the head of the dianetics
operation
out in california and so
[Music]
van vote would would later leave as
things start becoming more and more of a
church because he really didn't he
didn't care for that
the dianetics operation as we find out
went broke after uh van vote took took
uh over but never actually went bankrupt
dude have been vote stretching out the
arrangements with the
creditors and he and his wife actually
open their own dianetics center
so
that's keeping them pretty busy until
they finally break in the early 1960s
with that and then you know church of
scientology goes its own way and
dianetics goes its own way now during
that period
van vote is not producing original
material
in
you know a full novelistic way you could
say instead what he's doing
is you know something that i think a lot
of us are familiar with taking
old already produced materials and
repurposing them in in what are going to
be called
fix-ups so during this this period and
we're talking about you know 1950 to
1961
van vogt is
taking um some of his his earlier
material in the pulps uh previously
published stories and then
seeing how can i make these actually fit
together and sometimes it's just by like
putting a couple transition things in
sometimes it's reworking the material
all together
you could say that he's already been
doing this because world of null a is in
fact a fix up before it's actually
called a fix up
and so um vanvo was able to churn out
about a book every
year from 51 to 61 but they're all fix
ups right expansions republications
based on stuff that he's already
generated and he's relying on his
reputation as
one of the great science fiction people
from that that previous era the 30s
and the 40s
so
a fix up is is what it's a novel created
by taking several
short stories could be serialized could
be
not really related but in the same
narrative universe
and then you edit them you connect them
up together you add some framing to it
you add some interconnections you might
modify characters somebody who's a
villain might become less villainous or
might become more villainous or you you
know introduce new technology and that
is what van vogt is doing and that is
what is producing
these novels so just to give you an idea
of the the
depth
maybe not depth maybe breadth rather of
his fixing up here's some examples of
his fix ups
slan
fix up
world of pata world of null a voyage of
the space beagle the mixed men the
weapon shops of issue the war against
the roll rogue ship the silky and he's
still doing this in the 60s with with
rogue ship and the silky in 1970 with
quest for the future
now of the the two novels that we have
here the weapon makers was originally a
serial right it was in astounding
science fiction in 1943 and then the
serial version is published in book form
uh with with a short print run and then
it was revised and we we see that in
1952 and that is the book that's
contained in this volume
the weapon shops of isher
which is kind of a different story
set in the same narrative universe
uh disconnected by about about seven
years
is
a fix up from three previously published
short stories
one of which doesn't fit in quite as
well i would say the seesaw
1941 then we have the weapon shop 1942
and the weapon shops of fisher uh as
well and so
you know there it's it's a bit more
fixing up right and then we could say
the ultimate fix up comes when
uh we get this in one volume right so
this is this is an interesting uh thing
if you look at the library of congress
data for this so this is not this is
2000 that ore books does this and notice
their description
two classic vanvalk works the weapon
makers and the weapon shops of isher
together in one volume for the first
time okay that's clear enough right
form the complete story of robert
hedrick and the empire of isher
now we're going to talk about that in a
bit who's this robert hedrick guy you
know how are the weapon shops connected
to the empire of isher
that that's
quite interesting that's being revealed
to us of course in in these stories but
bringing them together into one volume
and saying okay here we've got the
whole universe that's kind of a fix up
too in a way
posthumously isn't it
so
you know that's probably enough about
this time you could think of van volt as
in this time period
being like an artist who has generated a
large body of music you know a number of
riffs a number of
compositions and going through and
editing the stuff together to make
larger
compositions why because he's he's
actually doing this as you know his
official full-time job but really what
he's focusing on he and his wife
together is this dianetic center so
there's a lot of interesting stuff going
on here biographically out there in
california as van vote is producing
these uh these works
there is nowhere near the amount of
criticism both positive and negative
focused on these weapon shops or issuer
novels as there was for example on null
a or voyage of the space beagle or some
of other um
van vortean works
but there is some interesting stuff out
there and some of what critics have to
say about
you know his other works or his work as
a whole does provide us with some some
useful context and and we're not going
to try to you know summarize everybody
but we will look at a few
important ones that kind of set the
scene so um
you almost can't talk about van volk
without bringing up damon knight who
just went after
jugular after jugular in his um
essay in in this this volume in search
of wonder
um so he wrote this this piece cosmic
jerry builder avan vote which is largely
focused
on
the world of nalae and he says this
chapter consists mainly of a long essay
originally titled the world event vote
which i wrote in 1945 for destiny's
child it predates my professional book
reviewing by five years i inserted uh
other passages later and then he sort of
you know
add some other things towards the end
and we're more interested in that
um if you want to see a real hard attack
on the world of nalay go ahead and read
the other stuff so he says i have been
progressively annoyed by van vote ever
since slan the first part of this
article has vented much of that
annoyance but there is a reminder there
are trends in van vogt's work as a whole
which which either do not appear
strongly in the world of nalae or could
not be treated in a discussion of that
story without loss of objectivity
so here's one key thing there is the
regifile trend for example it strikes me
as singular that inven votes story
nearly all of which deal with the future
the form of government which occurs most
often is the absolute monarchy and
further that the monarchs in these
stories are invariably depicted
sympathetically this is true of the
weapon shop series the mixed men series
and of single stories such as air
apparent the hero of the latter being a
benevolent dictator if you please
i am attacking van vote on literary not
political grounds so i shall not say
what i think of a man who loves
monarchies neither do i think it
relevant that these stories were written
and published in a time when both van
votes country and ours were at war with
dictatorships except in so far as it
serves to accentuate this point
obviously van vote is no better
acquainted with current events than he
is with ancient or modern history the
absolute monarchy was a form of
government which evolved to meet feudal
economic conditions everywhere and which
has died everywhere with feudalism
modern attempts to impose a similar
system on higher cultures have just been
proven very decisively to be failures
monarchy is dead and it can never revive
until the economic conditions which
prove produced at recur it is no crime
for van vogt as a private citizen to
wish that this were not so but ignorance
for an author is a crime so that's an
interesting point and we do have to take
up that
political theory
issue
a little bit later
he says another trend is the plot
wherein the leaders of two opposing
parties turn out to be identical for
example slan the weapon shop this trend
appears not only in van vogt's work but
in several other astounding writers and
i suspect that the final responsibility
rests with
campbell right and he says the plot
device was used by gk chesterton the
beautiful effect of the man who was
thursday and it was effective precisely
because the impression the author wanted
to give was that of utter and imbecilic
pointlessness
in van vogt's hands it gives the same
impression
but without chesterton's charm
he goes on a little bit further and
he tells us a few other things it is a
strange world that vanvo wanders in in
that dark and murky world medieval
rulers ride rocket ships supermen count
on their fingers the leader of the left
is also the leader of the right and
every hero packs a 32 caliber
improbability in his hip pocket
in the absence of heinlein hubbard to
camp and the rest of astoundings
vanished pre-war writers vanvo stands
like a giant but he is no giant he's a
pygmy who's learned to operate an
overgrown typewriter so some real harsh
stuff there
i will point out that um
knight later in 1974
says that
vanvo has real has
has just revealed for the first time as
far as i know that during this period he
made a practice of dreaming about his
stories and waking himself up every 90
minutes to take notes that this explains
a great deal about the stories and
suggests it's really useless to attack
them by conventional standards if the
stories have a dream consistency which
affects readers powerfully it's probably
irrelevant that they lack ordinary
consistency is that really a take back
of his criticism i actually think it's
kind of a deepening of his his criticism
so that's you know that's one
important sci-fi writer and critic who
criticizes many others especially in
in this book
going after van vogt on
you know a couple arguably problematic
rounds as we'll see
does he have any defenders
indeed he does
so
philip k dick
said that van vote was quite important
for him
in this vertex interview he's asked what
sci-fi writers have influenced your work
the most dick said
i started reading sci-fi when i was
about 12 and i read all i could so any
author who was writing about that time i
read but there's no doubt who got me off
originally and that was a even vote
there was in van vote's writing a
mysterious quality and this was
especially true in the world of null a
all the parts of that book did not add
up all the ingredients did not make a
coherency now some people are put off by
that they think that's sloppy and wrong
but the thing that fascinated me so much
was that this resembled reality more
than anybody else's writing
insider outside science fiction and then
he's asked a follow-up what about damon
knight's famous article criticizing van
vogt
and dick says
damon feels it's bad artistry when you
build those funky universes where people
fall through the floor it's like he's
viewing a story the way a building
inspector would when he's building your
home but reality really is a mess
and yet it's exciting the basic thing is
how frightened are you of chaos and how
happy are you with order van vogt
influenced me so much because he made me
appreciate a mysterious chaotic quality
in the universe which is not to be
feared
so dick is revealing to us
a different
side a different
way of looking at the
admitted logical
inconsistencies and often i mean
you know the the title cosmic jury
builder
it's actually not that far off
and you know if vanvo is drying on
dreams and doing fix ups and you know
putting all these things together
maybe it's that it doesn't have the same
kind of logic that knight wanted
and that somebody like philip k dick
could in fact recognize
and you know there's another
great follow-up on this in ted joya's
fix-up artist the chaotic sci-fi of a
even vote
he says i can enumerate many virtues of
van vogt's wacky novel talking about
world of nalay but resemblance to
reality would not make the list then
again i've never died on planet earth
and awakened on venus or like dick
received secret messages from outer
space so maybe i'm not the best judge of
the matter in any event i have a better
appreciation of the attitude of boris
vyanne the surrealist surrealist author
and jazz musician who translated the
world of nale into french as an exponent
of the culture of the absurd and an
obsessive fan of trendy populist art
from the us vyan had found an ideal role
model in van vogt
he says we may be better able nowadays
to appreciate the merits of van vogt's
fiction the disjointed novel is more in
vogue today
than at any previous point in history
with fractured tales such as david
mitchell's cloud atlas tim rockman's the
imperfectionist he goes on for a while
here teaching us that a collage of plots
is sometimes more effective than a
dominant storyline also a couple of
generations of postmodern fiction have
increased our tolerance for
discontinuity and juxtaposition as valid
techniques for constructing a novel
but above all van vogt fits in nicely
with the popular culture of our day in
which loose narratives or
anti-narratives in computer games music
videos reality tv have replaced the
tightly scripted tales of an earlier era
face it we live in an era in which
content almost always wins out over form
in which bound volumes of the
encyclopedia britannica are replaced by
messy search engine results in which the
personal memoir is superseded by the
tweet and status update
in that kind of world van vogt is hardly
old-fashioned and his
ultra-fast-paced fiction might even be
the right role model for our time now i
think there's really a lot there to
recontextualize
these novels as well as other novels of
van vogt because
you know they are admittedly kind of
loosey-goosey
in the plot right and in the the
connection between things there's a lot
of loose ends that are never
really tied together adequately or when
they are you're like oh i don't know
about that
the characters i i i don't know do we
want to say that van vote is able to
develop pretty
good
solid character development um probably
more for male than female characters
it's interesting because you know
there's there's two strong female
characters in these
works um
so that's something we could we could
put to the side
um
but there's a lot like i said to
recommend that i want to come back to
the to the
night criticism again because knight
also
stood in the way of van vogt getting
some of the recognition that he probably
deserved harlan ellison
campaigned for
van vogt to be you know awarded a grand
master award
and it only happened in in 1996.
ellison said van vote was the wellspring
of wonder that's how important he was
and then came the dark years during
which the man was shamefully agented and
overlooked and even the brightest star
loses its piercing light if observed
through the thickening mists of time and
flawed memory
now it is lifetimes later and the great
award has at last been presented to some
less charitable than i
something could be said about a day late
and a dollar short but not i i am here
to sing the talent electric and it is
better now than never he is the grand
master a.e van vote weaver of a thousand
ideas per plotline creator of alien
thoughts and impossible dreams that
rival the best ever built by our kind
this dear gentlemanly writer whose
stories can still kill you with a
concept or warm you with a character now
joins the special pantheon so that's
that's some pretty high praise by yet
another science fiction writer who by
the way didn't pull punches with anybody
i mean harlan ellison if people
people thought that damon knight was
kind of a jerk harlan ellison even more
so
there are two other things that i wanted
to read one is is also by ted joy and
and the reason i'm bringing this up is
it will lead us into
uh the discussion of character and world
building and some of the the
philosophical themes
he tells us
van vogt's heroes usually have some
superior philosophical system or mental
framework that gives them an edge in
their dealings with others in the 1948
the world of nolai gilbert gossen or
gosan renounces aristotelian logic in
favor of albert
alfred korabinsky's theory of general
semantics and voyage of the space beagle
dr elliott uh grosven winner repeatedly
outwits his fellow astronauts by
applying the science of nexialism a
method for integrating different
disciplines into a holistic view nat
kemp in the 1969 phil fix up the silky
relies on the similar arcane logic of
levels at times van vogt seems to forget
he's telling a story and adopts the
shrill tone of a huckster delivering a
recruitment pitch but the fervor of his
delivery and van vote skill no doubt
tested in his non-literary endeavors for
hinting at dazzling revelations known
only to initiates impart a unique flavor
to his stories reading them you feel
like you've been handed some inside
information akin to a hot stock tip or
surefire bed at the racetrack right
and that is definitely the case with the
weapon shops and the
technology and the disciplines that they
have developed in this there's a lot of
sort of like making up these
you know
well they've got these miraculous powers
but they come through
new sciences sort of sort of deal right
the last one that i want to read is
alexi
ponchin and man beyond man the early
stories of ae van voigt
and the abyss of wonder
and he says something very interesting
here
because he was a reader a writer and a
thinker van vote regarded himself as an
intellectual but if he was an
intellectual it was not of the usual
sort
he wasn't silver-tongued or swift-witted
he had very little ability to remember a
pr precise fact or exact uh point and no
talent at all for linear thought and
logical analysis he was not a
conventional man of reason
rather van vogt's usual method was to
fix on some question or subject in a
highly single-minded way to surround it
and dwell upon it and absorb it he might
get nowhere with a problem for the
longest time
but then at last the penny would drop
and some insight would pop into his mind
when van vote had enough insights
accumulated on a topic they would
assemble themselves into what he would
come to think of as a system
a methodology or a motive approach that
had its own consistency
if only in the manner in which it was
applied by him
in later days van vote would even take
pride in describing himself as mr
system
so i think that's kind of an interesting
idea there there's something like
you know in some ways socratic think
about socrates and his contemplation of
things until boom something would happen
but also we could think about pascal's
discussion of the
uh you know intuitive and geometric mind
or you know
actually it's the esprit de finess not
not you know it's
intuition
but finesse
a capacity to grasp a lot of different
things and then the esprit de giamo tree
you know
there's there's there's something
interesting going on there and it gets
folded into
these stories not just in the
construction of the plot but also in as
we just mentioned
some of the
ways in which the characters themselves
are thinking out
problems
and the tools that they're using
for that so all of this literary
criticism i think helps us to
center what we're going to do is we now
dig into
these
these worlds in these novels
it's time now to delve a little bit more
deeply into the world building that is
going on
in van voight's two
isher novels the weapon makers and the
weapon shops of isher
separated from each other in terms of
the action by about seven years but
really set within the same
narrative universe because it's a
narrative universe in which things
except in this story don't really change
all that much and
what we find out early on in um
the the weapon makers is that the action
is taking place about 7 000 years into
the future from our own time or at least
from the 1950s
in which this this poor guy gets sucked
in
he goes into a weapon shop gets sucked
into time itself starts swinging back
and forth we're actually not going to
talk that much about him
and that theme which doesn't fit in all
that well with um the rest of the action
instead
what we should think about is
what is the world like
so
until the very end of the second novel
humanity is essentially stuck within the
solar system and earth is all
under one government and we'll talk
about that in just a moment
and the
all the other places within the solar
system essentially colonies
of earth are just under that government
as well
and the government is the
you know
empire of issue
now
calling it an empire
you know we shouldn't imagine like
everything is under the one single
authority and everybody hangs on
her
you know every saying or things like
that there's a lot of
places that the imperial power
can't
effectively extend itself to
and the house of isher
is only one
polarity or one side of this grand isher
civilization in addition to that we have
the weapons shops which we'll talk about
much more as sort of a separate theme
but we'll have to talk about a little
bit here they are an organization that
is based around a particular fairly
loose
we could say social and political
philosophy
also possessed of incredible
technological power
and they provide a counterbalance to the
empire itself
to keep it from becoming
too tyrannical they don't do so in
a direct way they do so by providing
certain services
and we'll get to that in a moment so
we've got these two polls but in between
we have a
vast assortment of other
we call them functions all of them
officially within the political
community of the empire of issue but
kind of doing their own thing so what we
see is that there's you know a police
force and a military
and all this other stuff under
the empire but the empire can't
effectively
get things done and then there's all
these commercial
organizations and companies and many of
them behave in rather predatory ways
there's plenty of opportunity for small
businesses giant conglomerates
everything in between the empire levies
taxes and tries to impose laws upon this
this you know vast
ra a range of of uh economic activity
and entities but is only partially
successful the empress
inelda
actually
blames a lot of the disorder
and the fact that there's never enough
money in the coffers for what she wants
to do on the weapon shops but
even without the weapon shops being
there you get the idea from the many
different interactions that are very
quickly sketched out or discussed by the
characters that there's quite a few
shrewd operators who are each skimming a
bit on their own or taking advantage of
ordinary common people
great example of this is when the the
young man one of the main characters
um
creel uh clark
it wants to become an officer and he's
told well you've got to come up with you
know five you got to come here and
grease my my palms or or else you can't
get your commission right and it's a
pretty large
sum
at the time and and so this is a prime
example or you can think about the
criminal organizations that are
operating you know within the society in
the
uh house of chance and within
the
place that that he's taken to
uh after that
when clark is is sort of captured so
there's a lot of different
let's call them nooks and crannies of
this incredibly vast empire now the
empire itself
has
let's call it a near monopoly on
deadly force of course the weapon shops
are also
part of that and now we should talk a
little bit about them we'll talk more in
more detail about them in just a bit but
what can we say about the weapon shops
themselves they sell weapons they also
provide information centers where you
can get genuine information about all
sorts of things that is gathered by
weapon shops operatives
and there's weapon shops courts which
have their own ways of working as as
we'll find out but let's talk about the
weapons so why do the weapon shops
provide the kinds of weapons that they
do
in order to
allow not just the weapon shops but
people to be a counter balance to the
criminal corrupt activity
and also the potentially
tyrannical government of the empire of
issue the weapon shops are not supposed
to
do more than that as a matter of fact
they are part of a vital equilibrium
that has been set up for this
community for this
culture and there's some very
interesting
observations that get made at a few
places
here early on
in the work there's a discussion of it
as being an age of corruption
now why
so
here we go this is this is a
a conversation
between a general
and um
the empress
uh inalda
and um
the the general says madam if it gives
you pleasure to destroy corruption one
individual at a time you have a lifelong
task ahead of you she didn't like that
there was a brutality in the remark that
reached deep into her she drew back i've
got to start somewhere she made a
gesture half threat half frustration she
said queerlessly
i don't understand you anymore general
when i was younger you used to agree
that something
ought to be done not by you he shook his
head the imperial family must sanction
not personally direct a moral house
cleaning
he shrugged as a matter of fact i have
more or less come around to the weapon
shop idea that this is an age where
people take to corruption
here's the key thing
whenever their adventurous instincts are
denied normal expression
the green imperial eyes flashed i'm not
interested in weapon shot philosophy she
was abruptly astounded he should have
mentioned the weapon shops in such a
fashion she flung the accusation at him
the grand old man was immune
madam he said when i stop examining the
ideas and
philosophies of a power that has now
existed for three thousand seven hundred
years you may have my resignation
and there's a bit more that
gets said here on the part of van vote
as the narrator that's worth looking at
the woman rejected the argument
everywhere she turned was this
semi-warship of the weapon shops more it
was an acceptance of the shops as a
legitimate facet of isher civilization
i must get rid of these old men she
thought not for the first time they
treat me as a child and will always
treat me this way
allowed she said isil general i'm not
interested in hearing the moral
teachings of an organization that is at
base responsible for all the immorality
in the solar system
we live in an age where productive
capacity is so great that no one need
ever starve crime because of economic
need does not exist the problem of
psychiatric crime can be solved whenever
we get a hold of the afflicted person
but what is the situation
she was hot now with a remembered rage
we just we discover that our psychopath
has been sold a weapon shop gun the
owner of a house of illusion is
similarly protected true in that case
there's an understanding between the
police and the houses whereby raids are
allowed but if any individual owner
should decide to resist we would have to
bring a 30 000 cycle cannon to defeat
him ridiculous and criminal she
continued on every side were frustrated
in our desire to end this eternal
wickedness of millions of individuals
who sneer at the law because they have
weapon shops guns
it would be different if these gun
makers would limit the sale of their
products to respectable people but when
any sort of scoundrel can buy one
a defensive gun interjected the general
softly defense of only exactly senen
elda a man can commit any crime then
defend himself against justice oh
furiously why do i even talk to you
general i'm telling you we have the
weapons that can destroy these weapon
shops once and for all you don't have to
kill the members but get an army
organized to destroy the shops and so
what we see here is inelda herself the
empress the one who's in charge you know
she's got a more
she's a very intelligent person but
she's got kind of a simplistic
viewpoint on where the
sources of corruption are within society
and she views the weapon shops primarily
as an enemy as a subverter of
order rather than playing an important
role within what we call the ecosystem
of order
and she has to acknowledge that the
police themselves aren't really doing
their job so houses of illusion and
other criminal enterprises can operate
and we find that you know we see
criminal enterprises and even
um let's call them criminally organized
legal corporations are doing all sorts
of things preying on people in these
works and we've got the distant
you know ruler who wants everything to
be better
but
translating that downward is quite
difficult so an age of corruption right
and her general says the weapon shot
people say this is an age where people
take to corruption when their
adventurous instincts are denied normal
expression
what would their adventurous instincts
be well one of these we're going to see
would be
going out to the stars
and
this is discussed later on because
one of the things that has happened is
somebody has discovered
an interstellar
drive
and
the
isher government
under inalda wants to keep that under
wraps you can say well why
why do that well because it could lead
to a destabilization and a fragmentation
of society
so
this is a a another conversation later
on
uh inelda is
is talking with um hedruck
and she says
um here we go we'll stand a hundred days
if necessary if an interstellar drive
should be developed the house of issuer
would under present circumstances be
opposed to it and he says well why
because
her voice was a resident force
our population would shoot off in all
directions in 200 years there'd be
thousands of upstart royal families and
sovereign governments ruling hundreds of
planets declaring wars like kings and
dictators of old and the people they
would hate the most would be the ancient
house of isher whose living presence
would make their loud pretensions
ridiculous life on earth would become
one long series of wars against other
star systems she went on totally it may
seem silly to think of a situation as it
would be 200 years hence but a family
like ours
that has ruled an unbroken line for more
than 4 700 years has learned to think in
terms of centuries on the day that an
administration method is developed
whereby controlled stellar immigration
is possible on that day we could regard
with approval such an invention
until then
she stopped because he was nodding
his lean strong face thoughtful you're
right of course that angle didn't occur
to me
no chaos like that can be permitted
so that's an interesting point of view
right
and this is something that comes up not
just in aven votes novels but we see
this for example in gordon dixon with
the door sign novels with cj chera and
the alliance union universe it's a key
idea that
maybe humanity the next stage in our
evolution is to
while remaining you know with some of us
here in our terrestrial home to go out
to the stars to
go beyond the solar system
and to spread throughout the
galaxy or at least the parts of it that
we can reach and colonize
doing so
would open up all sorts of possibilities
but some of those possibilities would be
of political
chaos
and that's a real danger how do you
reconcile these and that's that's part
of why isher civilization is turned in
on itself
there's another
discussion of
the nature of this a little bit
later on
here we go
the the issuers are learning
that
they are human beings as well as rulers
and the world is a big place too big for
one mind or group of minds to comprehend
in its entirety right
and um
this is this is quite quite interesting
here
there's an offer being made right as
things are coming to a close
she came forward and placed his hand on
his he took it and kissed it there were
tears in his eyes as he straightened
your majesty he said huskily i beg your
forgiveness
i should have remembered the strain you
are undergoing you have but to command
me we have power a billion men will
spring to arms at your command we can
threaten the weapon makers with a
generation of war we can destroy any man
who has dealings with them we can
and here's where uh inalda is showing
wisdom
she shook her head hopelessly my dear
you do not realize what you're saying
this is an age that would normally be
revolutionary
the necessary disorganized mental
outlook exists the evils are there
selfish administration corrupt courts
rapacious industry each class
contributes its own brand of immoral and
immoral attributes which are beyond the
control of any individual
life itself is in the driver's seat we
are only passengers
so far marvelous science the immensity
of machine production the intricate and
superb organization of law
and she hesitated then went on
reluctantly
the existence of the weapon makers as a
stabilizing influence had prevented an
open explosion but for a generation at
least we mustn't rock the boat
i'm counting particularly on a new
method of mine training recently
released by the weapon shops which
strengthens the moral function as well
as performing everything that the other
methods are noted for as soon as we get
rid of the menace of the giant
organization
we
and and she goes on now she's realized
who the
the
giant is and the organization it's
actually her her lover and a man that
we're going to talk about at greater
length but notice what she has said
there she's had a realization about the
nature
of the society that she lives in that
even she with as much power as she has
at her disposal
can't completely reshape it along the
lines that she wants and she'll actually
have to as the representative of the
house of issuer cooperate with the other
great power the weapon shops
even against this other third power that
comes in so i think that's that's
probably
enough of the the discussion of world
building i do want to say one other
thing
there's not a lot of
long
intricate discussions as you might find
in other
sci-fi or fantasy writers about the
complexities
of
issuer civilization and going into a lot
of you know
extensive world building there i mean
look how thin this book this volume
containing two books actually is
so aven voigt has to sketch things out
as he does in all of his works by
shooting out you know very
short
but
rich vignettes that
capture the
the essence of the the world that they
are within
so that said let's move on and talk
about some of the facets of this world
and some of the philosophical themes
that come along with them
in my view if there is
any one single
theme that we
absolutely have to address it's the
weapon shops
themselves right this is the the weapon
makers or the weapon shops and the
weapon shops of isher the very titles
of these works
and
there's a good reason not just because
of the centrality of them to the entire
plot and world and you know
the the message i guess you could say if
there is one
running throughout van vote's
novels here and you know ostensibly
through a lot of his other works but
also because the weapon shops have
become something that has
captivated other people and been
co-opted in our society by other people
as well and what i have in mind by that
is the slogan that we see you know in
the sort of like the placards or the
the uh
advertisements for the weapon shops
there's a slogan that the weapon shops
used in vanvote that has been co-opted
by among other things the national rifle
association one of the
most powerful and pernicious lobbying
groups
in the united states
that is metastasized into a cancer
within our own society and so this this
slogan is the right to buy weapons is
the right to be free this is van vogt
at his finest in coining
slogans in bringing together ideas and
this is a governing idea
for the weapon shops in a way very very
different
than what we see in our society with
appeals to the second amendment and the
right to bear arms the right to trade
the right to buy and sell
and um the right to engage in in all
sorts of intimidation through carrying
around weapons as a matter of fact
most of the people who today bring up
that slogan
via the nra are people that within
van vogt's story would actually be
condemned as
thugs or
criminals or
ideologues you know and probably would
have you know wouldn't have been allowed
a weapon shop gun for the reasons that
we'll talk about
so this is something really worth
keeping in mind and we're going to come
back to that in just a moment but i do
want to bring up a
phrase uh these wonderful this wonderful
organization right as hedrock is going
to call it
so hedrock uh gazed at the gleaming
display of revolvers and rifles and he
was briefly shocked to realize that more
than 100 years had passed since he had
last visited a weapon shop now hedrock
is
mortal so
it's he's got lots of time on his hands
it made the shot more interesting than
it might otherwise have been
he had a sudden awareness of what a
wonderful organization the weapon makers
were with their shops existing in tens
of thousands of cities and towns in the
far-flung issuer empire an independent
outlawed indestructible altruistic
opposition to tyranny it was sometimes
hard to believe that every weapon shop
was an impregnab impregnable fort and
that bloody earnest attempts had been
made by the issuer governments in the
past to smash the organization now when
you talk about it that way it sounds
very black and white right the bad guys
the tyrants the
you know
quashers of freedom and then those who
defend freedom and they have their
castle they have their
shop they have their homes their
organization they are the beleaguered
you know champions of justice you know
think about these other
uh descriptions independent
outlawed indestructible altruistic now
what this points out
is that
the weapon shops
play a vital role within isher society
they do in fact
with you know with a few mix-ups here
and there mainly due to not thinking
things through as far as they they could
and so they need some course adjustment
adjustments they do in fact stand up for
freedom within the isher society
in a way that
benefits many many people especially the
common people
they do so as an organization
not just as one person doing concealed
carry
or
one person you know claiming to be
against tyranny and you know in in our
case usually misquoting founding fathers
or something like that
they do so as an organization and they
do so as an ethical organization
to which you cannot be admitted
or belong unless you actually are a
good person not just a person who stands
up for their rights or is going to
resist tyranny that altruistic is just
as important a term there as is the
independent or people like to
romanticize outlawed right
a lot of people are outlawed because
they're genuine scumbags and the empress
does in fact
raise an important point
would you put a gun in the hand of a
psychopath
the weapon shops would not
right
so they're not for anybody can get arms
under any circumstances as a matter of
fact what we also see is that the weapon
shops do not cooperate with
the police they do not cooperate with
the military
if you're a police person you can't even
get into the shop whereas an ordinary
person can
so the ethos of this
in this this slogan you know the right
to to buy
arms is the right to be free
the right to buy weapons is the right to
be free
very very very different than what we
normally think about
here in the united states and i think
that even
would be
repulsed by what he sees today
so that's a really important set of
points to get across at the beginning
about that slogan now let's talk about
what the weapon shops
actually do
there's some discussion of their
origins and this tells us about what we
could call the teleology you know the
ethical purpose
of the weapon shops and a criteria by
which we can ask whether they're doing
their job
so lucy roll is a weapon shop
person
and she's explaining things to to kale
um who she's going to marry and is in
love with right
she says the weapon shops were founded
more than 2 000 years ago by a man who
decided that the incessant struggle for
power of different groups was insane and
the civil and other wars must stop
forever it was a time in the world that
just emerged from a war in which more
than a billion people had died and he
found thousands of people who agreed to
follow him
his idea was nothing less than that
whatever government was in power should
not be overthrown
but that an organization
should be set up which would have one
principle purpose
to ensure that no government ever again
obtained complete power over its people
now notice it's not saying
that we would curb the power of
government altogether or little
government is the best that's not the
weapon shop philosophy
right
it's rather no government will be
allowed total control over its people
how
a man who felt himself wronged should be
able to go somewhere to buy a defensive
gun
you cannot imagine what a great forward
step that was under the old tyrannical
governments it was frequently a capital
offense to be found in possession of a
blaster or a gun
she went on earnestly what gave the
founder the idea was the invention of an
electronic and atomic system of control
which made it possible to build
indestructible weapon shops and to
manufacture weapons
that could only be used for defense
right so weapon shops
guns can't be used to engage in crime
they can't be used to
you know settle scores with somebody
that you don't like they can't be used
to simply try to overthrow the
government they can't be used to enforce
you know some sort of ideology against
another person
they can be used to defend yourself
and the guns are smart enough to know
when you're bsing about defending
yourself and when you're actually
defending yourself so that's that's an
integral
part of this and notice that she's
talking about a person
being free from the government in this
way but it also means being free from
criminals it also means being free from
corporations or other
blocks that would use power against a
person so this is the origin of it we
get the origin coming up again a little
bit later um
in uh the weapon makers which makes
sense you know he's gotta gotta rehash
the the thing hedrock um is is reminding
um the empress
about history and he says it's apparent
you've all forgotten your history or
blinding yourself to the reality
the weapon shops were founded several
thousand years ago by a man who decided
the incessant struggle for power of
different groups was insane and that
civil and other wars must stop together
he goes on a little bit further
and that an organization should be set
up that would have one principle purpose
again to ensure no government would ever
obtain complete power over its people
and then there's more discussion of that
at first people thought that the shops
were a kind of underground
anti-government organization that would
protect them from harm now here we get
to see another important aspect of the
shop
gradually they realized the shops did
not interfere in issue life
it was up to each individual or group of
individuals to save their own lives the
idea was that the individual would learn
to stand up for himself and that in the
long run the forces that would normally
try to enslave him would be restrained
by the knowledge that a man or group
could be pressed only so far
and so a great balance was struck
between those who govern and those who
are
governed
so this is very important now notice
what he's saying there
the weapon shops make
guns very affordably available to people
so that they can in fact defend
themselves and prevent the government
from coming in and taking everything or
even taking their their guns
but
the weapon shops don't give guns out to
people willy-nilly
and
there's sort of a back and forth there
the weapon shops themselves are governed
by their own
purpose and ethical code which is not to
let any jackass who wants to like feel
like they're big by carrying around a
gun have that as a matter of fact they
would probably not get guns all those
sorts of people right there would be no
hoarding of you know 20 guns in your
your gun safe or anything like that for
the the weapon shot people they would
look at you and say you've already got a
gun you don't need a whole bunch more
these are not fetishes right
he goes on a little bit further and says
it turned out a further step was
necessary
not as a protection against the
government
but against rapacious
private enterprise
civilization
became so intricate the average person
could not protect himself against the
cunning devices of those who competed
for his money accordingly a system of
weapon shop courts was set up to which
people could turn when they felt
themselves aggrieved in this fashion
this is equally important part then vote
in setting up the weapon shops as kind
of heroes and actually putting this in
hedrick's mouth hedrock by the way he's
the person who set up the weapon shops
in the first place right as we find out
so he's giving a lecture about what he
did to empress uh inalda who by the way
is related to him because he's also
the founder of the house or at least the
steer of the house of isher
so
what we've got here is an organization
that because of its technological
resources and because of its you know
consistent ethics
uh
uncompromising on that sort of stuff and
because it can measure these things and
guide them and direct them and they keep
their eye on the ball all the time
it can perform this function take away
the weapon shops and replace them with
this vague notion of you know freedom
through buying guns from anybody who's
going to sell them and you have an ethos
almost not just different
but antithetical to that of the weapon
shops here in this story
we find out some some other things the
the method of the weapon shops i'm going
to read this passage as well
[Applause]
so this is back in the weapon shops of
of isher
and um
there's a a interesting point we're
going to talk about pharah and the
um
transformation that he has
and um when he's being supplied his his
weapon and pharah says oh i i you know i
i've changed my mind about all these
things the old man in the shop says
the weapon shops will not countenance
any words against the empress and will
give no further aid to anyone who is so
indiscreet like you she is to some
extent adrift on the tide of our
civilization i will not enlarge on our
policy the worst period of our relations
with the imperial power was reached some
40 years ago when every person who was
discovered receiving aid from us was
murdered in some fashion your
father-in-law was one of them
we put in we put a stop to their murders
by killing the three men from the top
down excluding the royal family who gave
the order for the particular execution
but we don't want that kind of bloody
murder we're not interested in any
criticism of our toleration of so much
that is evil it's important to
understand we do not interfere in the
mainstream of human existence we're not
there to be like
total reformers we're not there to take
power ourselves
we're there to
help
we right wrongs we act as a barrier
between the people and their more
ruthless exploiters
generally speaking we help only honest
men
that is not to say we don't give
assistance to the less scrupulous but
only to the extent of selling them guns
which is a very great aid indeed and
which is one of the reasons why the
government is relying almost exclusively
for its power on economic chicanery
right and he goes on and he says
this is again part of a event philosophy
i would say
in the thousand years since the
brilliant genius walter s delaney
invented the vibration process that made
the weapon shops possible and laid down
the first principles of weapon shot
political philosophy we've watched the
tide of government swing backward and
forward between democracy under a
limited monarchy to complete tyranny and
we've discovered one thing
people always have the kind of
government they want when they want
change
they must change it
and as always we shall remain an
incorruptible core and i mean that
literally we have a psychological
machine that never lies about a man's
character an incorruptible core of human
idealism devoted to relieving the ills
that arise inevitably under any form of
government
and
it's a vast organization they have the
actual shops they have the shop members
who are sort of an interlocking set of
cells there's a council that as we find
out
we also find out in uh
there's actually kind of a couple cool
places
where
lucy rall is going to reveal some some
things to us each member has a kind of
cover identity when she's going into the
um
house of illusion to try to get
her lover out kale
what we find out here we go is that
lucy named a well a firm well known in
the city all this was simple and long
prepared for by the weapon shop every
weapon shop member was listed as a
worker in an organization which was
either secretly owned by the shops or
else owned by a weapon shop supporter
thus if a member was questioned in the
normal routine of issue commercial life
legitimate and checkable answers could
be given so there's there's you know
like a second life being uh developed in
in that sense
there's also another interesting passage
where they talk about
how they
treat their membership now she's going
into this
house of illusions
and
[Music]
i'll just read this this section
it seemed to her shakily that the weapon
shops would separate her from their
organization for even
considering
such a thing but when her mind
automatically flashed back over the fine
print of the document she'd signed she
couldn't recall any prohibition in fact
some of the sentences were positively
sensational when examined in her present
situation here's one of the sentences
weapon shot people may marry according
to their desire
participate in or partake in
any vice or pleasure of issue for
personal reasons there are no
restrictions on the use made of a
member's spare time by the member
it is of course taken for granted no
member will wish to do anything that
might harm his or her standing with the
pp machine we'll talk about that in a
sec as everyone has clearly been told
periodic examine
examinations by the pp will determine
the status of a member's continuance
with the shops in the event of members
discovered to have fallen below the
requirements at any vital degree
the weapon shops will relieve the
individual of all weapon shop memories
and information the person
of which by unauthorized persons might
be dangerous to the shops and then it
lists the following vices and pleasures
when pursued with too much ardor have
proven in the past to be initial steps
in the severance of relations and
what's really interesting about this is
they're saying listen
you're an adult you're
a person who's ethical you can figure
out for yourself what vices and
pleasures you can participate in if you
go too far we're going to kick you out
and we'll wipe your brain too of
anything pertaining to the weapon shops
because you're no longer serviceable to
us but it's up to you to decide what you
do with your life if you can handle you
know narcotics or uh you know sexual
relations of different sorts or whatever
else is is available for you if you can
handle it and still remain not pure but
a good human being well that's that's
fine
don't experiment too much
because sooner or later
you're probably not going to stand up to
all of it but it's up to you the weapon
shops are about
freedom
all right
so i think that that's a good
summary of the
a number of different themes that come
up with these
weapon shops let's talk about some other
things now
we've already mentioned that there are
two great polls of issuer civilization
and you could see them as like
force emanating from them directed by
them we've got the house of isher
where
inelda right now is the empress
both at age
25 and age 32 and one story and in the
other
and then we've got all the people
working for her right and then we've got
the weapon shops themselves and we do
have some other
characters mixed in there where you know
like like for example
um
the uh
clarks you know farah clark
and kale clark and what's what's
happening with them
and then we have a very important third
character that we're going to talk about
a third force who is the person
responsible originally for the weapon
shops and for the current status of the
house of isher and that is this
character hedrock who plays such an
important role not only in the first
novel but but even more in the second
novel
complicating things even more
is that we have a fourth force
aliens spider aliens now
why did man vote put these aliens in
there could he have done
the story without them i i think so but
they are kind of an interesting
little twist that gets added and so uh
we may as well uh hit on them
um and when hedrick takes this this uh
ship out
um and all these things are happening um
[Music]
he finds himself in a different place a
vague bluish light began to grow around
him he saw the city was indeed gone in
its place was an unearthly dark blue
world and webs miles and miles of webs
they reared up towards the remote
ceiling and vanished into the distance
of the dimness they spread out in all
directions fading into the semi-night
like things of some netherworld
mercifully they did not appear to be
inhabited at first hedrock had time to
brace his brain for the most terrible
shock its highly trained structure would
ever have to face he had time to grasp
that this was the interior of the ship
and that there must be inhabitants
far above him there was suddenly a
flicker of movement spiders he saw them
plainly huge things with many legs and
grew tents with the bitterness of his
realization
so a tribe of spider-like things were
nature's prized package the supreme
intelligence of the ages rulers of the
universe the thought seemed to be
in his mind a very long time before a
faint light focused on him from a hidden
source
and then thunderbolt of uh mind
vibrations rock his brain we'll talk
about that in a moment i just want to
mention very quickly though that
in
david humes
uh dialogues concerning natural religion
there's a number of different
conjectures that are put forth by the
skeptic who says
you know if you're gonna have like one
of these arguments from design about the
universe why do you assume that it's the
god that you know you're getting from
the bible
why couldn't it be like a whole
committee of gods
or you know why couldn't be a giant
spider and we're seeing that come up
here um and so these these things they
don't actually
understand humans which of course is is
perfectly understandable
um
and
so
they're they're sort of like
experimenting they're asking questions
man why did one brother make a long
journey to find out what had happened to
the other brother why did you risk your
life so that other human beings can go
to the stars and why do you want to give
the secret of immortality you know and
here's here's an important insight
in spite of the tattered state of
hedrock's thoughts understanding began
to streak through
these spider beings were trying to
comprehend man's emotional nature
without having themselves a capacity for
emotion here were blind things asked
asking to have color explained to them
stone deaf creatures being given a
definition of sound the principle was
the same and so they they you know they
monkey around a bit in the plot they
don't actually play a major
role i would say and they they come up
again
later on towards the very end
uh here we go this is in
chapter 17 of the weapon makers
here's a conversation between them an
interesting example of an energy impulse
continuing as if no outside force had
been applied no the purpose the answer
was cold the man was aware of us the
purpose driving him was carried through
in spite of his knowledge of our
existence clearly then he acted
illogically possibly but let us bring
him back here and they go on
um
and then eventually
they you know they they start having a
conversation
with him
and
um
in the very end
they
tell him that they are not here we go
we are not quite what we seem
the spider thought said our race is not
as you suggested one of nature's
successes
in this ship is actually the remnant of
our people
all of us here present are immortal
winners in the struggle for supremacy
and existence on our planet
each and every one of us is supreme in
one field by virtue of having destroyed
all competition we intend to remain
alive our existence unsuspected by the
several other races in the universe
because of an accident that precipitated
you into our midst you must die is that
clear
it is our intention to make a final
investigation of man sensory equipment
on the basis of what we've discovered
through you then leave this portion of
space forever the investigation will
take some time you will please have
patience until then there will be no
answers meanwhile to your petty appeals
conduct yourself accordingly
right so you know these are kind of
interesting aliens aren't they and
they're basically saying well we're
going to kill you but not quite yet
please please hold on until we do and so
is this you know a great philosophical
theme i wouldn't say so
uh it's it's certainly a kind of a
puzzling first contact
and i think that then van vote in in
this very short uh set of uh passages
is conveying you know what it would be
like to meet a genuinely alien species
so that's a good point
another one of the key philosophical
themes that
i wanted to talk about not least because
damon knight had brought it up by way of
criticism
is the role of let's call it the big
person the person who has the power who
can affect change and whether they can
really
accomplish that
or
not
do they have to be a super person in
order to do that so let's contrast
two characters in particular we have
empress inelda who as we mentioned
earlier in one of the passages she wants
to root out the corruption she wants to
be a great empress both in the sense of
being powerful and being obeyed but also
in the sense of actually
you know getting things properly
done the way they're supposed to be
being ethically
good and sometimes she you know loses it
a bit for example when she condemns head
rock to to death um
you know early on one of the novels
later she'll of course recant that but
there are some passages that are
particularly
good this way there's in in the the
weapon shops of isher we have um
we have uh
kale right who is trying to get in with
this this colonel who he's met while the
colonel was drunk
and the colonel had promised him a
commission
and then um
the
the emperors pops up on the video screen
it was the loudness that brought kale
out of his blur of emotional reaction he
was still ashamed of himself but it was
a shame of something that had happened
he had a sudden picture of himself
he keeps going and before the woman of
isher his gaze touched her face in the
stat without flinching he bowed slightly
and that made him feel better he had no
doubt now of her identity at 25 the
empress inelda was not the world's most
beautiful woman but there was no
mistaking her long distinctive face and
green eyes it was the face of the isher
family of emperors and empresses her
voice when she spoke again was her stat
voice familiar to anyone who'd ever
listened to her anniversary greetings so
different though to have her speaking
directly at him what is your name young
man
it was medlon who answered quickly his
voice tense but calm an acquaintance of
mine your majesty you turned to kale
goodbye mr clark i enjoyed your
conversation i said what is your name
the woman ignored the interruption it
was spoken so straight at him that kale
shrank but he gave his name and why are
you in medlin's office
cale caught medlin's eye a tense eye was
striving to attract his attention a
remote part of his brain had admired
medlin's skillful earlier words his
admiration failed the man was in a panic
deep inside kayla hope started he said i
was inquiring about the possibility of
attaining your commission in your
majesty's armed forces i thought so said
the empress in a level voice
she looked thoughtfully from kale to
medlin then back to kale
she looked young and alive and
gloriously confident and something of
her experience and handling men showed
then instead of asking kale the next
question she gave medline a way out and
may i ask colonel what your answer was i
informed him your majesty his commission
would require about two weeks to put
through as you know there's a certain
amount of red tape and then she says yes
colonel i know but too well this whole
rigmarole is only too familiar to me
somehow or another the young men who
normally buy their way into the army
have heard something is up and so they
remain away in droves and she goes on
she's very interested in what is
happening in her empire but she can't
effectively get the things done that she
wants to even when she concentrates like
a laser on particular
schemes and as we've mentioned she she's
realized the world is a big place by the
end we also find out that she has had a
kind of
brain training you could call it
she said here we go
um for a moment she was alone she stood
a faint smile on her long-ish her face
content growing into her tired body it
shouldn't take too long the menu
millennia ago had planted the education
of the members of the imperial family
had rightly judged no ruler could
survive in the age of science without
some course of training that would
synthesize all knowledge and discovery
into one brain
the training had evolved slowly it was
far from perfect
captain hedrick had told her that it was
similar to that of a weapon shop no man
resembling the ladder as much as a
caricature resembled a paragraph it was
a bitter comparison but she still felt
pleased with it so she has a lot at her
disposal
she still can't get everything done what
about hedrick though hedrick is at a
great advantage
over the empress
over even the other weapon shop people
in that he is immortal now he's not
immortal because he was blessed or
because uh he comes from you know some
pre and you know ancient immortal into
the modern age you know something some
weird experiment happen he's been trying
to replicate it for a very long time
without success and it allowed him to be
immortal and as such
he could do things that other people
couldn't because he's got a lot more
time on his hands
even still though
he gets tripped up
so
here we go this is uh early on in
the storyline
and we find out that
yes
this is in the wet the weapon shop of
isher a little more than a year ago he'd
applied for weapon shop membership his
given reason being that he expected a
crisis between government and weapon
shop forces he desired to be on the
weapon shop side his papers were in
order the pp machine gave him so high a
rating and every mental physical and
moral
category notice that moral category that
his file was immediately brought to the
attention of the weapon shop executive
council from the beginning he was on
special duty and his assignment to the
coordination department during an
emergency was a normal step in his
meteoric rise to weapon shot power
hedrack was aware of few members of the
council and a number of the top
executives considered his ascent too
rapid and not in the best interest of
the weapon shops he was regarded by some
as a mysterious figure though no
sinister connotations were intended by
the critics but nobody actually
questioned the verdict of the pp machine
which puzzled him at times he would
investigate the machine more carefully
later and discover why normally
skeptical men accepted its judgments
without qualification it had proven
inordinately simple for him to fool it
lie to it tell it his carefully doctored
story he had special control of his mind
and abnormal technical knowledge of
machine reaction to biological processes
there was also the overruling fact of
his friendliness to the weapon shops
which undoubtedly
helped right
and
he goes on a little bit further um
talking about um
you know
it was an invention that had developed
since the last time he had been a member
of the weapon shops 100 odd years ago
and so earth's one immortal man friend
of the weapon shops to make sure
it was as effective as safeguard as they
thought now a little bit later
in
the other the other book right we find
out that
his measurements did raise some problems
and we see
uh cadrone was was trying to speak and
cadrone
is going to
explain some things he says i assure you
mr hedrock we are all distressed by the
duty that devolves upon us but the
evidence is relentless here is what
happened
when the psychologist discovered the
variation two cerebro geometric
configurations were set up on the pp
machine one used as a base the old
record of your mind the other took into
account a 75 percent increase in every
function of your mind every function not
only courage
this brought your iq high and then head
direct says you say every function
including idealism and altruism i
presume
and khadron said
mr hedrock a man with that much altruism
would regard the weapon shops as merely
one factor in a greater game and that is
exactly what hedrock is doing isn't it
his altruism extends beyond
the let's call it cast or background or
anything like that he goes on and he
says
the weapon shops cannot be so
broad-minded
and the complicated configuration of the
empress was mechanically woven into the
matrix because speed was an essential
the possible influence on the situation
of other mines was reduced to a high
level constant modified by a simple
oscillating variable in spite of himself
hedrick found himself becoming absorbed
and the problem again
was to ensure the rescue party did not
arrive right so the the machine is
giving some some guidance to things but
then
here we go it was a nightmare all those
years when he had been living and
planning carefully building up the
structure of his hopes he'd actually
committed his fortunes to the pp machine
possibly the greatest invention
developed in the field of the human mind
and it turns out that
you know his measures are
not actually off the charts but but much
too
high
and
what we find out is that
hedrock can't get by with this he has a
life that's only existing
in documents
he can't hide himself from the weapon
shops forever at the same time
we later find out that
not only is is are the weapon shop
something that's been guided by hud rock
but he was actually the person who
arranged this
right that
he's arranged that and he's also been a
husband to
empresses
in the course of history
so
um the empress herself actually
discovers this with the help of the no
man gonish
and so it's turning out that hedrock
himself
is this this big picture figure who's
putting everything together and you know
the other complaint that damon knight
had about well we find out that it's the
same you know the right is the left and
they're both on the same page hedrock is
is doing that now is he ultimately
successful
in his aims well what are his aims the
further development
of humanity and keeping either side of
the usher civilization
from destroying the other
side of of isher civilization
i guess you could say that he is
successful in that he is a typically van
voteen
superperson
but he's perhaps one of the more
attractive ones
in in the picture
and we end
the book the empire of isher this entire
saga with the aliens and so i'm going to
end here with this
the aliens are talking about the empress
who chooses to give birth to her child
even though it's going to kill her
and
in some respects um
you know leaving
robert behind right
half a light year distant the 100 mile
long ship got underway inside it
thoughts vibrated from mind to mind
the second general examination is almost
as futile as the first in its basic
results we know some of the laws but why
did this ruler who possessed a world
give her life for her child when
actuality she shrank from personal death
her reasons that she personally must
carry on her line are logically
inadequate it's only a matter of slight
atomic rearrangements many men and women
are alive who could carry forward her
tribal progression
it remains but to bring her back to life
and make a record of the emotional
reactions of those around her to her
resuscitation
so and so is the weird spider name has
investigated the appearance of our
former prisoner hedrock at the palace
and it appears that he nullified by an
ingenious method the logic that required
his destruction accordingly we can leave
the galaxy within one period this much
we have learned here is the race that
shall rule
the
sevagram the whatever that is going to
be so the empress is going to be brought
back to life and she will rule with her
consort and humanity is now ready to go
out to the stars so kind of a happy
ending all around
has it been brought about by headrock
or by
many other characters including the
aliens
um
kind of a good point to
leave off on
[Music]
you